this is the Jocko underground podcast
Echo Charlie yes sir and me Jocko
willick so
I got a question kind of indirectly
um and it was about feeling jealous
which can be a big problem for some
people and it can be let's face it
there's all kinds of different jealousy
that's floating around you could be
jealous of uh
of you know a girl
or jealous you know of your girl if
you're if you're a man you could be
jealous of your woman if you're a woman
you could be jealous of a man I mean if
you're a man or whatever whatever
relationship you're in I guess we're
gonna cover all the bases you can be
jealous of your significant other
is that right are you jealous of them
yeah what is it technically called I
think you're jealous
I don't know yeah you're jealous of the
other person not you're not your spouse
or girlfriend boyfriend it's the other
person that they're interacting with
usually right that's the scenario so you
get filled with jealousy yeah I guess is
what happens you can also be jealous of
people's position in life you can get
jealous of people's success you can get
jealous of material objects
there's all kinds of stuff you can get
jealous of
or that can make you feel this jealousy
and
I can say that I've never been a very
jealous person
in fact I would say I'm not jealous I
don't get jealous
and I I have uh so why do I feel that
way how do I feel that way
um I think that
I think that jealousy
is
a manifestation of being insecure yeah
and your ego is threatened
and you have low self-esteem and so
you're nervous right you're nervous you
see your little bit of paranoia and
whatnot
and I feel like I'm you know pretty
confident with whatever and and not only
that I'm okay with
like there's some people that are better
than me you know as much as it's nice to
say well you know I'm a confident person
so I don't really get jealous that's
cool but I'm also I feel like hey
there's people that are better than me
at whatever you name it there's people
that are better than me there's people
that are smarter than me there's people
that have more money than me there's
people that are more athletic than me
there's people that are in better
position to me like there's all these
things
foreign
and I think more than just saying oh
well but I'm still confident it's like
no I'm humble enough to say hey you know
what there's people that are better than
me on a bunch of different things and
that's okay
now to get to the point of hey
how do you not be jealous here's where I
think I think you're gonna like this
mentality or approach
as far as and because it reminds me of
one of your stories that you told me a
long time ago which you told us I told
everyone on the podcast
which was I think it was you you read
the book Mind Games is that your book
and it said if you get mad
you have a little selfish
and so you were like oh dang I shouldn't
get mad anymore and that was the mental
trick that you played on yourself
to get you to a point where you viewed
being angry as sort of a weakness that
you didn't want to partake in anymore I
think you can use the same mind trick on
jealousy which is
hey if I'm getting jealous
that's me being insecure and here's the
thing and this is why this is why I
think it's even more effective
because
I want you to think about this I want
people to think about this not you
necessarily you Echo but
if you get jealous
that means you're insecure and here's
the Here's the Clincher
everybody knows it that's the thing your
everybody knows it when you're jealous
and you start freaking out what are you
doing talking to him everybody knows oh
you see that person as a threat you're
threatened by this other person that's
why you're getting jealous because
somewhere you think you're weaker poorer
Dumber
inferior to this other human yeah
so don't and and then guess what you
look like guess what you're
significant other now now thinks now
they think oh well why would why would
he be jealous of this guy this guy must
have something that Jocko doesn't have
instead don't do that don't allow
yourself to get in that trap
when you're jealous you're in it means
you're insecure and everybody can see it
so don't act that way even if you have
to just gut through it
even if you just have to gut through it
that is 10 times better
then saying oh I don't want you to go
talk to that guy right now yeah cool
I'll be over here yeah what
wait a second why aren't you jealous oh
I'll tell you why because I'm not
threatened you want to go with that guy
over there cool yeah go ahead that's
cool I'll be over here
that's fine
that's what I'm saying so if you want to
if you want so you can apply this to
anything right you can apply this to
anything you're at work
and someone's trying to butter up to the
boss and you're like wait a second I
what are you talking the boss for I
everybody can see it and somebody like
yeah you can talk about Soul you want of
course yeah oh you're you want to go
above me in the chain of command you
want to go check in with you with the
CEO cool yeah go ahead of course
go talk to him go find out what's going
on do you have no problem with that yeah
because I'm secure in my position the
minute I'm like what you're talking to
him everybody can see that now all you
you don't want to be found out as the
weak leader you don't want anyone
talking to the CEO and ratting you out
why because I'm paranoid why am I
paranoid because I'm insecure
and here's the key part everybody can
see it
everybody can see it
this is stupid what a jackass drive in
that nice car okay
yeah everybody can see it you think that
you're actually fooling someone and
thinking you don't like nice cars yeah
everyone can see that you're jealous of
the nice car everyone can see it yeah
so restrain yourself
because it's a bad look and it doesn't
help you and it puts you in an inferior
position in life
bad look huh yeah like you know guys
will be like or people whatever they'll
be like uh
what's he compensating for you know like
if you have a nice car or a nice
whatever well it's compensating for
yeah it's real obvious yeah but I guess
okay so the jealousy and you kind of
brought up a good kind of point there
where if it's like if it's with your
let's say okay just typical relationship
will say your girlfriend I don't know
and she's talking to like another guy
God yeah is that jealousy technically or
is it just simply insecurity well it can
be both if I'm insecure hey Jessica why
are you talking to him right now yeah
you're not only insecure you're also
jealous yeah it's both yeah so they're
like they're they're intertwined yeah
huh I I'm actually not that mad at
certain or insecurity in certain points
of a relationship to me the relationship
part of it gets a little bit more what
are you talking about like hard to just
switch it on and off for some reason I
don't understand what you mean okay so
like expand if someone's jealous and I
don't know this just could be my bias
which probably is I don't know but if
let's say someone's doing better than
you in XYZ I don't know some activity in
life maybe in the career or something
it's easy to like okay if you feel if
you're feeling some kind of jealousy or
whatever it's easy to switch that off
with that kind of stuff I think it's
like
it's really easy I think for whatever
reason but if you're in a relationship
especially a newer relationship
and you actually really like the person
yeah yeah so so what you're talking
about is the thing that I have to often
talk about when it comes to Leading
teams and leading people compared to
leading to your family let's compare to
Leading your family when you're dealing
with your family when you're dealing
with uh the loved one yeah you got
emotions and the emotions are what you
have to try even harder to keep in check
because you might be a little bit upset
with your employee if they do something
that they shouldn't have done but you
might be totally irate with your kid if
they do something they shouldn't have
done so we got to keep our emotions in
check and it's even more so when it
comes to this idea of someone you know
potential partner going with talking to
someone else or doing you know you got
to be even more controlled over your
emotions and here's the thing
your
girlfriend boyfriend significant other
they think less of you when you get
jealous
yes that's what's happening yeah that's
true and if you can do the opposite
it's going to be better for you and it's
going to be better for them and it's
going to be better for the relationship
yeah
yeah fully and that that's obviously
true
but
it can't I feel it because you know okay
so when you when you I don't know I
think it's called pair bonding or uh
something where when you get a
relationship with somebody of like this
thing some chemical reaction oxytocin or
something like this
okay true story we will consult the Bro
Science
so now you have this
oxytocin okay so anyway do you have that
going on it's so it's kind of oh you
should write a few you need to write a
Bro Science manual like I will maybe I
don't know maybe maybe I won't I don't
know but either way I'm I'm saying
essential chapters this this scenario
this phenomenon whatever is makes it
like harder to just be like oh yeah I
don't feel jealous you know well I'm not
I don't feel insecure right if you're
insecure in a relationship which to me
again and my point here isn't that like
oh it's so hard and that's not the point
the point is
I don't think it's all that negative to
feel insecure in a new relationship
especially if you like the person so if
you like the person yeah you of course
you're not going to feel secure you
haven't been with them that long you
haven't established like a a
legitimate relationship with a person
yet
okay I don't think it may I'm trying to
see where you're right here I think that
you could be correct that it's okay to
feel a little bit insecure in the
beginning of a relationship because you
don't really know them that much
but I'm still gonna say that you'd be
better off stifling that emotion and
being cool instead of acting like an
idiot yeah yeah so more the behavior
piece yeah
save your peace yeah fully yeah so I
remember I remember thinking about this
whenever when I got into the new
relationship where they'd be like no the
relationship should be built on trust
you know and I was like yeah of course
that sounds good but after I thought
about I was like wait it can't be built
on trust you don't even really know that
person that good or you don't know how
it is to be in a relationship with them
not good it's new so essentially it's
kind of backwards in a way where it's
like No it should trust should be built
on the relationship really more so than
a relationship should be built on trust
because you can't just start handing out
trust you gotta you know yeah it's just
like developing like uh trust inside of
a working relationship yeah if I'm
working with you I don't give you a
massive project and just say good luck
all right it goes good no I give you a
little project you do good on that yeah
trust goes up exactly right same thing
with a relationship right so if the
girl's not actor or the guy is not
acting right it's like okay boom you
kind of take note or whatever but you
also are yeah yes yes and what I was
going to say is
I apologize for cutting you off but
eventually you're like wait a second
they've broken the Trust on this little
thing so I'm not going to continue down
the road of this relationship anymore
right so but if you really like them or
the oxytocin runs strong or whatever
that part right there that part that you
just said that becomes like hard I think
you're connected to it primally that's
why so it's just harder you can do it in
the behavior piece like you said I think
that's really the critical thing
any this reminds me of when we've talked
about how to deal with breakups before
and like my advice which I have not
heard better advice than
walk away don't look back and that's
what you need to do
walk away and don't look back and here's
the thing if you want to have a chance
of getting that person back the best
thing you could do
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground